روسيا لن تجلس مكتوفه اليدين بانتظار
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد المتوقع دفاعات
مكثفه بنتها خلال هذه الاشهر وبينتها صور
للاقمار الصناعيه اربعه مواقع اساسيه دخلت
ضمن خطط روسيا الدفاعيه وتقع جانبيعها
جنوبي اوكرانيا اولها الساحل الغربي لشبه
جزيره القرم والمشهور سابقا بمنتجعاته
الشاطئيه على الساحل المنتدمه مسافه 25
كيلو مترا استبدلت موسكو كراسي التشميس
والمظلات بكتل خرسانيه هرميه الشكل مصممه
لسد مسار الدبابات والمركبات العسكريه
الاخرى خلف هذه الخرسانات خط من الخنادق
والمخابئ يوفروا غطاء من الهجمات القادمه
وسط ترجيحات بان تكون هذه الدفاعات اجراء
احترازيا وليس توقعا لهجوم الاوكراني بحري
لان الاخيره تمتلك قدره بحريه محدوده خطه
روسيا تشمل مدينه الصغيره هذه المدينه
الواقعه على طريق رئيسي جنوب شرقي البلاد
يمكن استخدامه قبل كيف لعزل القرم عن
الاراضي الاخرى التي تسيطر عليها موسكو
شبكه ايضا من الخنادق حفرت في خطين شمال
وهو الاتجاه الذي يجب ان تهاجم اوكرانيا
منهم وخلفها توجد حلقه اخرى من التحصينات
من ثلاث طبقات من الدفاعات مع احتمال كبير
لتواجد الالغام بين خطوط الدفاع خط من
الخنادق والخنادق المضاده للدبابات يمتد
على مسافه 35 كم من الطريق السريع الرئيسي
اي واحد صفر خمسه وهو غرب توكماك والذي
يربط بمدينه خاركيف اما رابع المواقع
الروسيه والمحصنه فهي في منطقه الجنوب
وتشمل وهو هناك خنادق مستديره قرب قريه
ريف نوبل الصغيره على بعد حوالي 55
كيلومترا شمل ماريوبل اذا كل خندق مستدير
به كومه من التراب في الوسط ربما لحمايه
المدفعيه او حتى السماح للجنود بالاحتماء
وتحريك المدفعيه حتى تمكن من التصويب في
اي اتجاه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات